jackie we are coming off quite
the season premiere how are you feeling
about
season 11 now that everyone's seen that
first episode
i feel like i'm ready for it to
i'm ready for the world to see it so i
can put certain parts of it behind me
because
i was really disgusted and disappointed
by the start of the season
you need to admit that you spread i did
not spread a rumor
i heard a rumor okay well you know what
i heard that gia snorts coke in the
bathroom at parties
okay i heard it i don't know where i
heard it from i mean i heard from
somebody here
i mean but it's the same thing so how is
that not the same
now you're i was not this yeah this is
not the same but i do
want to say first off that my analogy
about gia there was
absolutely no truth to that it was
definitely just an analogy i was trying
to make the point about saying
you know how words can hurt if you were
to just say something about someone you
love but
she's a great girl and i'd never want to
hurt her reputation so i just want to
make sure everybody understands that it
was really just to get theresa to
understand
at the very end of a long and
frustrating conversation
how i was feeling what happened she
brought up my daughter
what happened what happened i said it's
the same thing as me saying that i heard
that gia snorts coke in the bathroom
she's disgusting
nope to bring up everybody he has four
kids frankly i was disgusted and angry
i was angry as hell at that moment but
you know i
did not like state a rumor i you know i
set an analogy together to understand
and that the fact that that went
completely over her head
i mean if she had understood that it was
an analogy we could have just continued
on the conversation on the couch
um but the fact that that went
completely over her head
and she heard that the name of a family
member and just lost her
all together um you know to me that
indicates that she thinks her family is
much more important than mine
and it just it was a disappointing
conversation it was a disappointing
start to the season
did you have any inkling that it would
not that she wouldn't get it
no okay honest to god i really i don't
dumb myself down
for for conversations with people who
are
not intelligent so i i mean i just
it was so clear as day that it was an
analogy that
i not even for a second and if i really
thought that she wouldn't understand
that was an analogy
i would never have said it ever
now that you've seen the reaction to the
use of gia's name though and
her comments on social media have been a
little flooded with commentary and stuff
and she's had to speak out do you regret
that choice um that's a hard question
because i feel like it was
it was so poignant in getting teresa to
realize
how bad it is to just make a blanket
statement about someone
you love so i don't i can't say that i
regret it because
if you come from my family like you you
can't just do that i mean
i think that she has this mentality that
nobody can fight back against her
because she'll just demolish them and
like
that's really not true and i think
people were really happy to see
somebody finally putting her in her
place everyone else on the cast gives
her a pass for every single thing she
does whether it's because they're a
family member
or because she has been a friend since
childhood or
you know in jennifer's case she's just
like obsessed with being teresa's friend
but
it's a hard position to be in the only
person you know
well where do we go from here i know you
took a step back
took a pause walk me through that
thought process and then how you knew it
was okay to return
sure so um the day after that
conversation
we were all supposed to leave for lake
george and there was just no way i was
setting myself up for four days
of just like torturous fighting
and um so there was no way that i was
gonna go on that trip i mean you
couldn't you couldn't pay me enough
money to go on that trip and at that
point i didn't know the stance that the
rest of the the women would take
and i said to myself well if the rest of
the ladies in this
group are going to stand with teresa on
this
then i'm not i don't know that this is
the place for me
anymore and i also needed to talk to
evan and make sure that he wanted to be
a part of this group and
you know and um the thing is that i
absolutely love
love being a part of the real housewives
of new jersey but
it's not my entire life so i needed a
breather it was a really heavy week
so that's why i didn't go are you just
gone for that one
girl's getaway or did you take more time
off
um i took about in total
um a week okay
yeah so i'm gone for the girls getaway
but then um
you'll see there's um i think one or two
events that i also had to
step out i mean maybe just one that i
also
didn't go to when you got to watch the
premiere episode and saw how everyone
reacted
to teresa running around evan's party
did that
make you feel good that they were all
like stop this
shut this down what are you doing
absolutely
and i think that i i think that
everybody was hurting for me they knew
how deeply this could cut especially
with me i really really love my husband
i love my family and like
i just you know they knew how devastated
i was gonna be coupled with the fact
that i'm prancing around drunk
eating evan's face off in this little
pink dress i mean it just couldn't be a
better setup for somebody to just like
tear you apart once i found out and then
i had to tell evan
and he was just beside himself he was
embarrassed and enraged
and you know everything was just coming
down on me
and rightfully so i mean he was really
really mad but my kids were upset
my daughter i remember would cry every
night asking if we're gonna get divorced
and like of course we're not gonna get
divorced over it but they they're
not used to us fighting what were you
fighting about though because i would
imagine you were a united front in terms
of
wanting to shut this down what was the
the fight about
so the fighting was really about the
fact
that i had brought this into our lives
you know and suddenly yes i know this
exists in like
tv lands but it also impacts our real
life
day-to-day i mean millions of people see
it millions people are reading about it
on the internet and he was
just beside himself he was so
embarrassed he was the one taking the
hit
and he was just so upset and embarrassed
and there was no one for him to
um kind of like yell at and be mad at
aside from
me and i was wracked with guilt because
i did bring this into his life
and so it was just like fight after
fight of
what do you want me to do i told you
i'll leave you know is that what you
want
and like it was just a lot of back and
forth and
indecisiveness and you know at the end
of the day i just had to
keep making the point of i love you more
than i love this
and i will leave if you want me to
you know and it was just a really
frustrating experience because i
felt so guilty and so heavy for it and
but there was nothing i could do to fix
it
well we get to see him share those
feelings
um not so much i didn't put the cameras
back on him
for a little bit he needed a breather
you know
but you you'll get to see him a lot this
season but just
not at his you know angriest yeah
okay uh i did get to talk to theresa
before the season and we went through
some of this and i want to get your
reaction to some things she told me
about
this debacle um she says this was not
premeditated she didn't come into the
season
wanting to tear you down do you believe
that no
she came to the party without a gift
that's number one
she was not there to celebrate my
husband she was there to start trouble
so um no i don't believe that it wasn't
premeditated she knew what she was doing
okay and she said she was just doing
this as a girls girl so that
and bringing it up so that you could
shut it down because it was out there
she didn't tell me she told every single
person at the party aside from me
so that's obviously nonsense okay
will there be resolution on this whole
rumor thing because
she was going back and forth saying
i don't remember who told me oh i do
know who told me but i can't disclose
who told me
is there resolution on that or does it
just kind of it is what it is
now there's absolutely resolution on it
but not
entirely because of
theresa um i did realize at a certain
point that i was giving her
way too much power to either you know
take this back
or you know keep it going and um
once once we took that power away from
her
um there we reached a resolution much
faster
but it's you'll have to tune in and see
because it's a really interesting
process for me to come back yeah it
sounds
pretty twisty turny what did you and
evan learn about your relationship
having
to go through this and now reliving it
yeah well um first we realized that we
really are unbreakable
and we weathered it so well and i'm
really proud of him because he was such
a
you know he put on his big boy pants and
he dealt with it and
you know at the end of the day come back
from it unscathed
you've teased kind of where things go
and from the trailer and from what i've
heard everybody's got something going on
what kind of ride are we in for what
else should we be bracing for
this we are i mean you get a
really deep look into
um the mechanics of everybody's
relationships and it's really
interesting because
things that you wouldn't i am very very
close with melissa and i never saw
cracks in her marriage and you
see all those cracks this this season so
i think it's just
you get insight into everybody's home
life
that we've never really seen before okay
is there anything that you're really
excited to see um
any fun moments you want to tease yeah
for sure um
our second trip so i didn't go on the
first one but the second trip of the
season
is so much fun once
once the nonsense is out of the way we
had so much fun and i think everybody's
gonna really love that because
i mean it's a dark heavy year and it was
a dark you know few episodes and
uh i think everybody's gonna be really
ready for some fun stuff we really did
have a great time
a great time and that's the down the
shore trip right yeah that's the kind of
short trip
and now that's also where the like
stop yelling about me stop yelling about
me and the cheese plate throwing and all
that
yes yes but it also had
some of the funnest times that i've had
anything else you want to say about the
season it's we're just getting started
but people are really responding to it
already
i'm really excited for people to see the
way that this plays out because you know
it's a lot of
it's a lot of heavy stuff and like we
work through it it's not just fluff and
i feel like that's really interesting
and um no i just love all the love and
support and
um just like a big thank you to everyone
who sent me like supportive messages
this week i loved it
[Music]
you